tyke is what we call talented but the
one thing i'm going to say is i keep
hearing from people that there were a
ton of deleted scenes so i am curious if
you could put something back in the
movie that you shot that wasn't in it
what would you put well this isn't even
me saying it but they're um well can i
when does this i don't i can hold it
till after release if you would like i
can't say steve but there's a lot in the
movie that i would put back in but
nothing salacious nothing crazy
i think what actually exists in the
movie is fantastic
and then maybe things will be released
in you know in the future in other ways
yes um
i'm very much hoping for that
one of the things that i love about this
is it's clearly tyka's imagination
running wild on screen i love this um
what is it actually like to work with
him and see
this kind of you know the way he works
on set and like what the energy that he
brings to something like this i think
there's a fair amount of organized chaos
which apparently comedy is the
introduction of chaos into an ordered
system so it sort of
makes sense that we work the other way
around that we first like create the
chaos and then
this is what tyka does i think is
creates the chaos and then after creates
the order so it's sort of like you have
fair game to to go down whatever rabbit
hole seems to be the most intriguing
interesting it's like we're always
trying to get ourselves on the precipice
of of breaking of it being so funny that
we can't contain ourselves and then it's
sort of after figuring out like no
actually we we need to pair this back
because we need to understand story we
need to understand stakes but it's kind
of this
you know imaginative space to go there
if you were doing it the other way
around and trying to sort of like in a
really didactic way tell a story and
then infuse a sense of play and chaos
it's kind of harder to get there in a
weird way if that makes sense completely
um was this your first time working with
the volume technology this was not my
first time actually um because we work
with it on westworld a little bit so i
had been i had been around it in that
context i was going to say i've heard of
that show as well yeah
that one's also kind of good
but i am curious like with that
technology it because i've seen like
clips and i've spoken to a lot of people
that use it yeah it does and i hate the
term game changer but it is like such a
revolution in the way you can tell
stories it is it's really really
immersive because for people that don't
understand it's like it's it's
essentially like you're inside of the
picture so the backdrop instead of it
just being a green screen or a blue
screen you're inside of the actual
environment and it's moving and it also
creates light and shadow and dimension
so it's fabulous but the thing that i
mean all the technology is amazing the
thing that i still feel so wowed by in
the context of making these movies is
actual all the practical stuff like new
asgard they built that town you know in
the middle of australia somewhere and
it's like you go into all the little
bars and nooks and crannies of the town
and it feels like you're in some
norwegian seaside town and that's the
artistry that's like human hands and all
the incredible things that people do
with you know the cg world and the
digital space
is is just like
human
brain mastery but i still like all the
stuff that's made with hands i'm just a
sucker for yeah i would have uh i wish
they would save that kind of stuff so
fans could actually go and visit i know
new asgard would really like it would
have really i thought that so much with
just being there i was like god fans
would love to be here this is so cool
and that no need to go i'm just gonna
say seriously congrats and i wish you
nothing
you